human on social media is also
a beautiful thing the absurdity the
absurdity and memes like i i just want
to like take a moment yes i love like
when we're talking about art and credit
and how and authenticity i love that
there's this i mean now memes are like
they're no longer
like it memes aren't like new but it's
still this emergent art form that is
completely egoless and anonymous and we
just don't know who made any of it and
it's like
the forefront of comedy and it's just
totally anonymous and it just feels
really beautiful it just feels like this
beautiful
collect like
collective
human art project that's like this like
decentralized comedy thing that just
makes it memes adds so much to my day
and many people's days and it's just
like
i don't know i don't think people
ever i don't think we stop enough and
just appreciate how sick it is that
memes exist and because also making a
whole brand new art form in like the
modern era that's like didn't exist
before
like i mean they sort of existed but the
way that they exist now as like this
like
you know like me and my friends like we
joke that we go like mining for mean
memes or farming farming for memes like
a video game and like like meme dealers
and like whatever like it's you know
it's it's this whole memes are this
whole
like
new comedic language well it's this art
form the interesting thing about is that
lame people seem to not be good at memes
like
corporate can't infiltrate memes yeah
they really can't they tr they could try
but it's like it's weird because like
they try so hard every every once in a
while i'm like fine like uh you got a
good one i think i've seen like one or
two
good ones but like yeah they really
can't because they're even corporate is
infiltrating web3 it's making me really
sad
but they can't infiltrate the memes and
i think there's something really
beautiful about that
you